we never wanted to discuss the trans
issue with any of these screaming loons
on either extreme you know Doug and
there are there are plenty of both sides
and I remember seeing you on good
morning Britain talking about it in a
way that actually okay well first of all
this person clearly knows what they're
talking about and also they're coming at
it from a sane angle right so obviously
one of the the crucial points in this
conversation now is the fact that you
have trans women competing in sports
right against cisgender women for anyone
doesn't know cisgender is someone who
was born female and his female right and
you cut what is your view on that for
anyone who hasn't seen it well well my
view controversially as far as trans
people are concerned is that I don't
think you can actually get away from the
fact that if you've been through a male
puberty the chances are not guaranteed
but the chances are that you are gonna
be taller bigger have a longer reach a
greater strides all of these elements
that will come into play if you're
playing a sport and I would divide it
into two areas this spot I think
obviously in in terms of keeping fit and
having fun and recreational then I don't
think there's a problem if everyone's
happy to accommodate people into that
environment then great but I think there
is a distinction when it's professional
sport at the highest level because to
reach you know the Olympic Games or
national championships in a particular
sport the chances are you're going to
have to have devoted your whole life to
achieving that standard building up the
strength the agility the skill etc and
what we have now we have transgender
athletes on the female side and who have
gone through male puberty who have been
athletes as guys and they're being sort
of middling media you know they've been
okay and they've may be finished sort of
fifth or sixth but now that they've
moved into the
the women's area you know they're
winning
they're coming top not consistently and
this is the important thing to say it
doesn't always happen I think there was
one year actually when Paula Radcliffe
was in a pomp she was actually the
fastest long-distance runner in Britain
bar none you know relevant of being
female compared to the man so it doesn't
always work that way
but I think that is a difference and to
say as some trans people such as Rachel
McKinnon who's probably the best-known
person and pushing this argument at the
moment for those who don't know she's a
cyclist who did compete before her
transition and you know finished 5th or
6th I would say but she's won a couple
of high-profile races since moving into
the the women's side of sports now
Rachel's view is that testosterone has
zero effect on performance and it's the
same with skeletal structure she would
argue that some women can be six foot
four which is true you know I've seen
Chinese basketball players for instance
who tower over everybody else but they
are anomalies and yeah you do get
anomalies just across humankind but I
think if you're gonna have sport and
Rachel does want to keep the distinction
between men and women in sports so she
does want those two separations going
off if you actually argue that
testosterone makes no difference to how
you perform as an athlete or going
through a particular puberty then aren't
you really saying that there's no need
to have a male and female division
you're just saying that we are all the
same so why doesn't Rachel just say
instead of saying I need to compete in
the women's division why isn't she just
argue if that's how she feels for
open sports you know that men should be
competing against swimming and I think
that's where the little bit of hypocrisy
creeps in with her argument if she felt
that it did make no difference
whatsoever
she'd be quite happy to compete against
the guys
[Music]